ministre des solidarités et de la santé
en février 2016 le conseil départemental
du haut rhin avait voté un dispositif
demandant aux bénéficiaires du rsa de
réaliser 7 heures d'engagement
hebdomadaire dans une association ou une
collectivité territoriale des âmes bien
pensantes
la ministre des affaires sociales et
même le premier ministre de l'époque
avait par des cris d'orfraie contester
la légalité de la délibération en
demandant deux déferrés dedans demandons
au préfet de déférer la décision devant
le juge administratif le conseil d'état
dans une décision courageuse vient de
donner raison au département du haut
rhin en considérant qu'un président du
conseil départemental est en droit de
suspendre le versement du rsa
lorsque le bénéficiaire refuse sans
motif légitime
cet engagement de cette heure il ne
s'agit pas de stigmatiser mais
d'intégrer et de redonner une dignité
aux bénéficiaires de cette aide sociale
cette mesure vise à réinsérer
progressivement ceux qui sont les plus
éloignés du marché du travail il faut le
savoir 40 % des bénéficiaires du rsa
sont dans le dispositif depuis plus de
cinq ans cette situation n'est plus
acceptable
le candidat macron avait soutenu l'idée
du bout des lèvres devant l'association
des départements de france et cette
jurisprudence mais aujourd'hui le
gouvernement devant le pied du mur
madame la ministre vous pouvez bien
entendu mettre fin par un texte
législatif à cette décision de justice
mais vous pouvez aussi retenir une bonne
idée qui vient des bandes à droite
ma question est simple est tout prêt à
soutenir une proposition émanant des
députés républicains afin de fixer un
cadre juridique clair et sécurisé et
favoriser le retour à l'emploi
est à madame agnès buzyn ministre des
solidarités et de la santé merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
strauss kahn straumann pardonnez moi
vous m'interrogez sur la question du
bénévolat en lien avec les récents et
sur le haut rhin comme j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire il y a cinq minutes
notre modèle social concernant les
minima sociaux doit être repensé en
profondeur est tourné vers l'insertion
des personnes
il n'atteint pas son but et le constat
est sans appel
tandis que les dépenses liées à la
délivrance des prestations ont augmenté
celles liées à l'insertion des personnes
ont baissé les départements en ont la
responsabilité
certains accompagne très bien les
personnes dans des mesures d'insertion
d'autres beaucoup moins bien
et au final notre système n'est pas
assez efficace c'est un échec collectif
parce particulièrement ce qui concerne
le rsa il faut mettre plus de moyens sur
l'accompagnement et l'insertion si nous
voulons changer la donne mais il faut
accompagner les personnes il faut les
former il faut les rapprocher de
l'emploi sans attendre que la spirale de
la pauvreté soit installé il faut aussi
agir sur les fins périphériques et c'est
particulièrement le cas pour les femmes
isolées avec des enfants mais aussi pour
ceux qui ont des problèmes de santé
en ce qui concerne le bénévolat je vais
être très clair je rappelle que cette
question relève d'abord de l'action des
départements qui exerce la compétence de
l'insertion professionnelle des
bénéficiaires du rsa le conseil d'état a
rappelé que l'accord des personnes est
requis et que le bénévolat ne peut pas
leur être imposée ce qui m'importe c'est
la réalité de contrat d'engagement qui
doit prévoir des modalités d'insertion
est un véritable accompagnement pour le
retour vers l'activité et l'emploi
c'est non seulement ce que prévoit la
loi mais c'est aussi un gage
d'efficacité et quels que soient les
choix qui seront réalisés par les
départements je demanderai de
l'efficacité en termes 2 en termes
d'insertion et de retour vers l'emploi
je vois
merci madame la ministre l'a pas